-Welcome to the show.
It is nice to meet you.
Thank you so much for coming on.
-Thank you for having me.
I've always wanted to do this.
-Yeah.
Yeah. Wow.
You did it right there.
Yeah, you -- That's it.
Thank you for
coming to New York.
I know you're probably coming
from L.A. or Australia.
-L.A.
-L.A., yeah.
Have you spent much time
in New York?
-I've spent a little bit
of time here.
I try to come sort of
as often as possible
to see the plays
that are on and everything.
But my parents are here,
and one of the biggest memories
I have coming here
was when I was younger.
And I came with them.
So this is one of my first --
-Where is your mom?
-I'm trying to find them
while I'm speaking.
-Oh, hey, there they are.
I see them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Hi, mom. Hi, dad.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Yeah, it's also
their first time.
-Yes.
-It's their first time
being on "The Tonight Show,"
as well, which is perfect.
-We're in it together.
-When did you come to
the city with your parents?
-I think I was 8 years old.
And we sort of did all the
stuff, like all the sights.
And I remember my dad sort of
surprised me with tickets
to a Knicks game, because I was
a big basketball fan.
-Oh, yeah, and where did --
-Yeah, we were in
the nosebleeds, up the back,
but I remember it was just,
like -- It was, like --
It was the most special
experience, though.
You know what I mean?
-Don't you have some news
to tell your parents?
-Yeah. We're going to the Knicks
tomorrow, but way closer.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, that's right. Way closer.
-Yeah.
-Now, the new season
of "Euphoria"
had a giant premiere on Sunday.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's become a huge, huge hit.
Did you have any idea
that it would be this big
the second time around,
the second season?
-No, I didn't know, and then
they told me this morning
that it, like,
crashed the website.
And, you know, a lot of people
have seen it, so it's -- Yeah.
It's so scary.
-I'll tell you what's scary.
You're getting your own
wax figure at Madame Tussauds.
-Yeah.
-Now, I'm lucky enough to be --
I've done it myself, as well.
Have you been through the
whole process yet?
-I did.
I went through the process,
and it was strange,
but the strangest thing is their
shirts that the crew wear
say like, "Paparazzi" and
like, "Celebrity."
That was the
strangest thing for me.
Like, you've got all these
cameras in front of you
and you've got all these
little dots on your face.
It looks like behind the scenes
of "Planet of the Apes."
And then these people
in shirts that say like
"Paparazzi"
and like, "Celebrity."
-Really? I didn't see that...
-Yeah, it was peculiar.
-...on mine.
-Great people.
-I don't know if you have
legit people doing it.
-It's like a gang of paparazzi
just, like,
gluing a picture.
-It turns out your
wax figure is this big.
-Yeah, it's a bobblehead.
-It's LEGOs. Yeah, exactly.
This show, "Euphoria,"
I will say,
is pretty dark at some parts,
pretty, you know --
It must be stressful
to do a show like this.
But I heard that
to keep it loose,
you would do you this thing
where you would grab
people's phones and just take
selfies with their phones?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Now, how do you go with that --
I like the bit,
but what is it?
-Well, it's not even, like,
"Euphoria"-specific.
I think was in New York a couple
of weeks ago and I was at a bar,
and someone had left their phone
sort of on a table somewhere.
And I kind of just, like --
There's something about it.
Like, I want them to find it.
I have this idea
that they're going to have
the phone for like 40 years,
and in 40 years' time,
they're going to be like,
"Oh, I'm going to go through
my camera roll,"
like they don't
go through it every day,
and be like, "Oh, my God.
Who is this?"
-No, they know who you are.
But you just grab
a phone and just --
-Yeah, like,
but I don't move it,
because I don't
want to be invasive.
So I do the slide up.
-Oh, that's very nice of you.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, thoughtful.
-Yeah, like a pigeon.
-Yeah, very thoughtful of you
to do that, yeah.
In this show,
you play Nate, who --
He's not really a good guy.
No.
But at the end of
Sunday's episode,
your character is
a little changed kind of.
Well --
-Yeah.
-He gets beat up.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-But fans were like,
"Well, he had it coming."
-Yeah, they were stoked.
They were so happy about it.
-And would you agree with that?
-Well...
-I mean, it is you.
-I think me as Jacob,
I would love to beat him up.
Like, I would love to give him
a clip around the ears.
But as Nate, you know,
I feel very bad for him.
-Yeah, because you are
his character.
You're playing
the character so well.
-Yeah, I had to get beat up.
-Yeah, and you don't want to get
beat up, but --
-It sucked.
-Yeah.
I want to show everyone
a clip from the show.
Here's Jacob Elordi in
the new season of "Euphoria."
Take a look at this.
-What's up, man?
You having a good time?
-[ Coughs ] Yeah.
-You make any
New Year's resolutions?
-No.
You?
-A few.
-The last time we talked, didn't
you say you wanted to kill me?
-[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, well,
to a new year, playboy.
-Oh, my God!
-Jacob Elordi, everybody.
"Euphoria" airs Sundays
at 9:00 p.m. on HBO.